do the flow arts have any effect on
mental health can they be part of a
treatment or therapy for illnesses or
other mental health problems
the answers to these questions are not
super clear yet but i'd still like to
take a look at these questions
nonetheless drex here from drexfactor
poi sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we're going to
dive into those brains big time before
we dive in i just want to give a quick
shout out to the friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing businesses
and what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard lane machinski and
becca beckonen thank you so very much
for your support for my work and my
mission it is mental health awareness
month here in the united states and
that's kind of ironic because
i myself have been struggling with a lot
of my mental health this month and i am
going to go for a walk
and take you all with me the reasons for
which i hope will be clear by the end of
the video so for those of you who don't
know i have major depressive disorder a
condition that used to be referred to as
clinical depression and that results in
my going through cycles where i have
difficulty getting basic tasks done
interacting with people and even in
severe cases engaging in self-harm i've
done videos before talking about the
specifics of how my depression manifests
but suffice it to say
i've been struggling with it pretty bad
for several months now and it's been
tremendously frustrating and exhausting
while my current depression isn't as bad
as the depression i experienced earlier
in the year or even last fall after i
was assaulted
i'm also just so fatigued from
experiencing it for so long that even a
bout of moderate depression like this
one
is just wiping me out because i don't
really have the emotional or physical
reserves to cope with it anymore the
good news is i'm not having any thoughts
of self-harm and i'm doing a pretty good
job of staying socially connected
i have been falling behind in work and i
am very frustrated about that fact but i
also have a great support network
including close friends and an awesome
therapist so as these things go i'm in a
pretty good position for navigating this
but it is still a fact of my life and
something that i wrestle with on a
regular basis so let's talk a little bit
about this from a broader perspective
specifically does poi spinning help with
this does it or any other flow art have
a therapeutic effect on my condition or
anybody else's
the short answer is
probably
there's very little research that's been
done here but the research that has been
done looks at least somewhat promising a
few years ago i did a video on the
health benefits of the flow arts that
incorporated as much current research as
i could find at the time most of these
studies focused on things like physical
health strength dexterity and even
coordination and cognitive functions and
in this respect flow arts in general
showed a great deal of positive health
impacts i'll link to that video in the
description and theoretically flow arts
could have great therapeutic impacts on
a variety of different mental health
conditions as well a 2020 paper from
lori sirs and julie meeks suggests that
poi spinning could help develop focus in
people with adhd help trauma survivors
to ground and re-inhabit their bodies
help people with anxiety disorders work
through negative self-talk and get
people with depressive disorders like
myself to be more active and interrupt
low mood states among many others these
are all hypothetical outlines though the
paper is a call for more research in the
area rather than a study that supports
any of these impacts or conclusions now
that said there was one paper i found
that did perform a study on people
learning juggling as a therapeutic
intervention for women with anxiety
disorders and found that when coupled
with therapy and medication learning to
juggle markedly improved outcomes for
patients being treated for anxiety over
a six-month span
big caveat here the sample size was
really small but here's the thing i
don't think we actually need a bunch of
research saying the flow art
specifically has a positive impact on
mental health though i welcome that
research if it happens don't get me
wrong
and this is because we already have a
wealth of research showing that regular
physical activity and being outdoors has
a positive impact on a variety of mental
health problems including my own to put
it more simply we don't need flow arts
to be a silver bullet in the therapy
world it works for the same reason that
yoga running and hiking do it doesn't
matter what your intervention or
treatment is just so long as you find
something that you do on a regular basis
flow arts is a great fit for that as are
many other physical activities there's
no wrong answer here so now i'm going to
pull it back into the world of anecdotal
evidence so take all of this with a
grain of salt but there is something i
want to highlight about that last study
i cited well it shows positive effects
on anxiety from learning juggling
that's also coming along with talk
therapy and medication flow arts has had
an enormously positive impact on my life
it has given me a fulfilling career been
my gateway into learning higher math and
allowed me to connect with incredible
people from all over the world to say
nothing of the ways in which it has made
me feel connected and present in my body
getting out and spinning poi has been
helpful to my mental health it has been
helpful in managing and stabilizing my
depression but it did not cure it i
still have depressive episodes i'm in
one right now flow arts and other forms
of movement therapy can be helpful
interventions but they should not be
thought of as either the only or even
best options for facing mental health
problems you know what wound up being a
tool that was just as if not more
powerful for me than spinning poi going
to therapy talking to somebody about my
destructive thought patterns and getting
some ideas of how to retrain them or
work around them i've known people for
whom spinning props has had an
immeasurably powerful impact on their
lives both physical and mental i would
absolutely recommend it to just about
anyone and if people are wrestling with
mental health problems
i would also highly recommend talking to
a mental health professional
that's their job it's what they're
trained to do
sometimes it takes you some time to find
one that is the right fit for you but i
swear to you it's worth it and in the
meantime one of those things i've
definitely lost track of over the past
few weeks has been my commitment to my
flow i've spent a lot of time trying and
failing to get myself caught up on work
and
well feeling an enormous amount of guilt
around that
i've spent quite a lot of time pushing
myself not to lose social connections
even as i struggle to remember how to
human
i have not however set aside time for
myself to come outside
and just flow for myself
so this video is kind of me making
myself do that
i hope you all don't mind
[Music]
do
oh
yes
will you call me
[Music]
well thanks for coming along on a walk
with me and for talking about mental
health i will confess i feel very
self-conscious about how short the
script is and feel like i should have
done more research
should i cover the topic in greater
depth but i'm also accepting and
forgiving myself for doing my best with
what i've got
i hope that you all can too i'll include
links to the research i cited in this
video down in the description as well as
to the service that i found my own
therapist through
if you or someone you know is struggling
and could use some help right now you
can call the substance abuse and mental
health services administration at
1-800-662-help
take some time to learn about mental
health disorders this month whether or
not you have one yourself a little
empathy can go a long way in making the
people around you feel more comfortable
talking about their own struggles and
the more openly we talk about mental
health and remove the stigma around it
the more people are going to be able to
live better
and longer lives because of it
[Music]
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going to help other people find it and
to help my channel grow this video would
not be possible if or not for the
wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description helped to make this video
and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to
patreon.com drexfactorpoi and signup you
can do that at the link in the
description or the card that just popped
up if you are watching on youtube there
you can get access to a whole host of
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
what is your mental health story has
flow arts helped you with your own
struggles what are they and how has flow
arts helped leave me a comment and let
me know i would love to hear your story
in the meantime i'll leave a link to a
playlist on some other videos i've done
on mental health down in the description
as well as up on screen if you are
watching on youtube make sure to get out
and flow today and i'll see you with the
new video on wednesday
peace